[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer pop star
britney spears will not be deposed by
her father's lawyer as an investigation
of her now terminated conference
conservatorship moves forward long
crimes andrea levy is here with what
happened at the latest hearing
angeannette
brian britney spears's father jamie
wanted her questioned by his lawyers but
judge brenda penny reiterated that that
is not going to happen as spears
supporters gathered outside of the
courthouse in los angeles
[Applause]
now spears has alleged that her father
jamie created that conservatorship to
control her life and enrich himself and
that her managers were a part of it
those former managers lou taylor and
robin greenhill have denied being a part
of creating the conservatorship but
spears's lawyer matthew rosengart
presented the court with emails that
suggested they were a part of it
rosengart wants to depose both of them
he also spoke about judge penny's
decision to not allow jamie spears
lawyers to depose britney spears
the decision was legally correct
but as a moral matter it was correct
britney obtained her freedom
last november
and as many of you know
particularly perhaps in light of recent
news britney is moving on with her life
she wants to move on with her life
and yet that man her father
her flesh and blood
does not want that the notion
of her father of all people or any
father
wanting to
take a harassing deposition
of their daughter
as i've said before
is morally abominable
now matthew rosengart said that jamie
spears took at least 6.3 million dollars
from his daughter's estate despite not
being her manager or playing some other
role he of course was her conservator he
said that you know he hasn't alleged
that that was illegal but he's saying he
hopes that jamie spears hasn't
squandered that money and he wanted to
know who's paying his legal fees
meanwhile jamie spears will be deposed
by august 12th and there are still
questions about whether or not that
deposition will be filed with the court
or possibly be subject to some type of
protective order that would keep it
sealed brian
thanks ange joining us today is legal
analyst melville pearson and co-host
terry austin melba why do you think
jamie spears wanted brittany to pose how
would that have helped him in the end
i think that the reason why he wanted
her deposed was to number one sort of
flesh out this idea that he was acting
in his own self-interest that he was
trying to enrich himself he was
hopefully going to try and get her to
say something along the lines of the
attorney was going to try and get her to
say something that either permission was
given or that he was that that she was
incapable of handling her affairs and
trying to show basically humiliate her
in a lot of different ways to help build
her case and luckily the judge saw
through that yeah speaking of seeing
through it terry the judge denied the
motion to file by jamie spears to compel
her uh her his daughter sorry her being
brittany to testify why do you think the
judge ruled in her favor
well the judge didn't think it was
necessary she thought that britney's
father jamie was trying to
harass britney and basically what
britney's father was saying was that he
wanted her to talk about how he might
have mishandled her finances but
britney's team said it was a revenge
deposition she had no first-hand
knowledge at all about the finances
that's why it was a conservatorship and
that going through such a deposition
would really re-traumatize her judge
penny agreed she said there's no need to
do this and in fact brian the judge said
there are other ways that you can get
this information from other people from
documents and not from britney so let's
not traumatize her all right let's
explore those other ways because
angeannette bernie spears is not being
deposed but what about her former
manager
well matthew rosengart says those
depositions brian are coming that was
supposed to be discussed at this recent
hearing but they ran out of time the
courthouse closed at 4 30 and so they
ran out of time because they were
arguing about all of this other stuff so
tristar is actually being ordered to
produce all documents and many of these
documents will pertain to this alleged
surveillance operation of britney spears
now
this includes audio recordings and some
monitoring of her text messages and
things like that from what we have been
told and the new york times actually
exposed this through a whistleblower
others involved have denied it but
matthew rosengart said that this can
this actually includes some audio
recordings that include communications
with britney spears and her lawyers
which would be a flagrant violation of
attorney-client privilege absolutely
well we'll see how this story the bernie
spears conservatorship
continues as more and more information
seems to be coming out of this case ang
thank you very much melbourne terracing
a bit the parkland school shooter
penalty phase trial is on hold until
next week as a florida jury will decide
whether he receives life in prison or
the death penalty 17 people were killed
and 17 more injured when the gunman
opened fire at marjory stoneman douglas
high school in 2018. last year the
shooter pled guilty to all council of
murder and attempted murder prompting a
penalty phase trial after months of jury
selection opening statements were
presented last week since then dozens of
survivors have taken the stand the state
is expected to rest its case sometime
next week for a complete recap of the
trial's first two weeks tune in to the
next episode of lawn crime daily
and in las vegas a homeowner narrowly
escapes a murder attempt and is all
caught on a ringed doorbell camera law
and crime network's correspondent sierra
gillespie has the story
an attempted murder caught on video as
ring doorbell footage captures a narrow
escape the footage released by the las
vegas metropolitan police department
shows the man running across the street
as a suspect chases close behind video
then shows the man wearing a pink shirt
run toward a gate at the same time the
suspect wearing what appears to be a
white t-shirt points a gun at the man
the dramatic video shows the suspect
repeatedly pointing the gun to fire as
it jams multiple times
after trying to shoot the man at least
three times the suspect runs off
officials in nevada now asked the public
for help identifying this suspect who
they believe is a black man between 18
and 25 years old they say the incident
happened on july 24th near lake mead and
thomas w ryan boulevard in las vegas
that's where the victim returned home
and parked his car in the garage after
that the suspect approached and quote
demanded property that's when the man
ran off and the suspect followed close
behind anyone with more information
about this incident is asked to contact
crime stoppers of nevada reporting for
long crime network i'm sierra gillespie
still ahead on law and crime daily a
one-time cult member shares her story
about life inside nexia but first the
death of george floyd 2x minnesota
police officers are sentenced in federal
court
[Music]
welcome back federal sentences are
handed down for two ex-minnesota
officers involved in the death of george
floyd
back in february jay alexander king and
tu tau were convicted of violating
floyd's civil rights the 46 year old
unarmed black man was killed in may of
2020 as ex-officer derrick chauvin knelt
on his neck for nine and a half minutes
king tau and thomas lane stood by as the
incident occurred on wednesday tau was
sentenced to three and a half years and
king was sentenced to three years both
are ordered to surrender themselves on
or before october 4. federal prosecutors
asked for a lesser sentence than derek
chovin who received 21 years but more
than thomas lane who was given two and a
half years sentencing in this case could
renew talks of a plea deal in king and
tau's state case both are charged with
aiding and abetting murder and
manslaughter that case is expected to
begin on october 24th
terry there were different sentences for
each defendant how do you think the
judge calculated these sentences
well i think it was probably the correct
calculation all of them violated george
floyd's civil rights but each one was
distinct obviously derek tovan was
primarily responsible that's why he got
the 21 years i think tao's sentence was
three and a half years because he was on
the force for eight years and he
completely ignored all the requests from
that crowd if you remember and then i
think king got the next number of two
and a half years because he kept his
knee on george floyd's back and that
contributed to the death as well i do
think the judge gave lane the less of
all sentences because remember he was
the one who said that he was concerned
about delirium and he said please turn
floyd over so i think that's why he got
the lesser sentence yeah i mean king and
lane makes sense to me but i thought tao
would have gotten less because he
literally had no hands on george floyd
but hey to each of their own but melba
do you think this sentence will push
king and tao to trial or plea in their
state cases
in my opinion i think that they're going
to be more likely to want to take a plea
in the state case especially if they can
work out a situation where the sentences
could be served concurrently if it ends
up being that it would have to be a
consecutive sentence meaning they either
have to finish their federal sentence
first and then go to the state then it
would be less likely that a plea could
be negotiated but i think because of the
fact that they're already going to go
into custody their career as a police
officer is completely over it is highly
likely that clean negotiations will
really go into high gear at this point
yeah it'll be interesting to see if the
prosecution comes back says you know
what six years we're not negotiating at
all or if they do what you say fall in
love with the federal charges as well
well in houston texas a shocking road
rage incident caught on camera when a
woman fires a gun near a two-year-old
boy law and crime network correspondent
sierra gillespie has the story
a road rage incident caught on camera as
a woman allegedly fires a gun into a
vehicle where a toddler was seated
it happened on july 26th on interstate
45 in houston texas sheriff ed gonzalez
says two vehicles were driving north
when they came to a stop that's when a
man and woman got out of their truck and
approached another man in his car the
victim says the man later identified as
34 year old benjamin green assaulted him
sheriff gonzalez says that as the man
tried to drive off the female suspect
40-year-old nazli ortiz fired a gun into
the back seat through the passenger
window the victim says his two-year-old
son was seated in the back of the
vehicle at the time
the victim was taken to the hospital
with a possible graze wound sheriff
gonzalez says both ortiz and greene were
arrested and now face assault charges
reporting for long crime network i'm
sierra gillespie
coming up on law on crime daily a look
inside the nexium cult a former member
describes meeting the infamous keith
ranieri
plus the alex jones defamation trial we
take you inside the courtroom for a
heated exchange
welcome back we're taking a closer look
now at the so-called nexium cult that
made headlines in early 2018 when its
leader keith renieri was arrested on
counts of sex crimes and forced labor
law on crime network sierra gillespie
hears from a nexium cult survivor now
working to prevent others from a similar
experience
in the very beginning um it was really
hard for me to say that that i was in a
cult it was very hard for me to even
wrap my head around it but now now these
days yes i was in a cult kelly teal says
it's no one's intention to join a cult
but years after her involvement with
nexium she's still picking up the pieces
i don't know how far i would have gone i
don't know if i had said yes and given
collateral and then found out the next
level of what was going on what would i
have done if i had found the next level
after that of being branded would i
would i have run out screaming now
associated with secret societies
blackmail body branding and the infamous
keith renery teal says her experience
with nexiums started much differently
they had this promise and this mission
of purpose in the world i jumped right
in i thought this is this is the answer
this is just going to be the answer it
has to be the answer in winter 2016 teal
stumbled upon nexium's executive success
program but by chance her first
experience with cults occurred nearly 20
years before i used to live across the
like small canyon from heaven's gate
when that happened but to her nexium
didn't relate to heaven's gate at all
there was nothing cultish about it going
into it in the 18 months she was
involved with the organization teal says
she met leader keith renery who she says
embodied a superstar type energy when i
met him my first reaction was sort of
like he's short
kind of nerdy looking and it was very
kind of awkward he asked me a few
questions he said he knew all about me
and i was doing great within within the
coursework now over time you start to
kind of buy this idea that he's special
like everybody sort of put him on this
pedestal do you know what i'm going to
say right now no
you're insecure about that is that scary
for you no why not because i trust
that what you're gonna say is gonna be
good
and in the end you're gonna be okay
in 2019 ranieri was convicted of a
string of federal crimes including sex
trafficking of children and conspiracy
by 2020 he was sentenced to 120 years in
prison follower allison mack of
smallville fame was also sentenced to
three years in prison i did have a
moment that was a wash from my right
side all the way over to my left side
that went through my body that was like
this opening that just said keith is
evil reneri known as vanguard to his
followers created the nexium self-help
program in the 1990s eventually
masterminding the secret society called
dos what appeared to be a women's
self-empowerment group was really a
front for creating sex slaves when i saw
that these slaves were giving the
collateral that word jumped off the page
to me and that's when i started putting
two and two together teal says she was
recruited to join dos but later learned
reneri spearheaded the group it required
women to provide collateral on entry and
brand themselves with ranieri's initials
i'm probably going to get flack on this
but they were good people allison mack i
don't believe is a bad person she did
bad things and she's paying for that now
i believe that many of the people that
are
were involved at the higher levels were
manipulated to some extent in the years
following her experience with nexium
teal now works to bring awareness to the
prevalence of cults in america there is
no one person
or one thing out there in the world that
has the answer
it's inside reporting for long crime
network i'm sierra gillespie
for more information about teal's story
or for occult support resources visit
the website on your screen
when we come back we head to texas for
the alex jones defamation trial what
happens when an argument breaks out
between attorneys from both sides that's
ahead on law and crime daily
welcome back to law and crime daily
things get heated between attorneys in
the sandy hook school shooting civil
trial in texas as a family of one of the
victims sue's conspiracy theorist alex
jones in december 2012 a gunman killed
20 first grade students and six staff
members at the connecticut school after
the shooting jones told his audience it
was a hoax and that he thought it was
staged with actors in order to push gun
control measures the families of several
victims and an fbi agent who responded
to the incident filed lawsuits against
the political conspiracy theorists over
his comments courts in both texas and
connecticut have already found jones
liable for defamation answering default
judgment against jones after he ignored
several court orders and failing to
respond to discovery demands ahead of
trial an austin jury will determine what
jones will pay in damages in his first
lawsuit trial jones later said he
believes the shooting did happen but
claims he has a right to say that it
didn't toward the end of the day
wednesday and after testimony was done
for the day things got heated between
both sides attorneys
maybe now's not the time maybe we can
cool off and i'm gonna have a phone call
later okay yeah sounds like you're good
okay
anything you're going to say no no
you can tell him and then we're not
going to have a fight and it'll be
mark do you have his phone number
we're having a fight right now write
your phone number down so we can get it
we'll call you after everybody cools
down a little bit on both sides
exactly which is why i'm trying to get
you voted no you can give me your phone
number federico i don't want to talk to
you anymore right now give me your phone
number write it down
i'll text it to you
i'm sorry it's like two grown men i'm
not sure if they're grown men at that
point but
what's your reaction to these attorneys
and their conduct about the admission of
videos
it's very disappointing and i dare say
disgusting uh because basically you
shouldn't be getting into you know
peeing matches not to be you know
whatever in the middle of core like you
have to have some decorum you have to
have respect for the process and of
course you're both going to zealously
represent your client but you know at
the same token you have to do so it with
decorum and in accordance with you know
the oath of office that we swore as an
attorney to uphold the law and to not
bring any disreputable actions or or a
bad look upon our profession and what
they did there was a very bad look and
unnecessary
we'll see what happens when those two
boys are out of their time out
jones uh terry jones has two default
judgments filed against him why do you
think he chose to ignore court orders in
two different states
you know what brian it was really not a
strategic move on his part and that's
putting it mildly it was really an
idiotic move he failed to respond to the
complaint in connecticut and in texas he
didn't respond to discovery orders so
both judges said listen you're liable
and we're going to go straight to
damages so i think that it made no sense
for him because now he cannot argue any
first amendment rights he's already been
deemed liable for the case and the only
thing remaining now is a question of how
much he's asked for a dollar against him
and of course we know that the
plaintiffs are asking for 100 million in
150 million in texas and i think he
really should have tried to defend the
case i think the uh amount is going to
be closer to 150 million
you know see how it plays out well melba
terry thank you and thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you